[Musique]
bonjour à tous sa vie de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal préparé par les
équipes de télé 78 nous sommes le lundi
13 décembre voici les titres de cette
édition
le vrac un mode de consommation de plus
en plus prisés les objectifs sont
nombreux
lutter contre le gaspillage alimentaire
et réduire les emballages ou encore
faire des économies tendance aux prises
de conscience focus sur ce mode de
consommation et les alternatives
yvelinoise le quartier des petits prés
des longs cours va être réhabilité un
projet de rénovation urbaine en
concertation auprès des habitants
jusqu'au 17 décembre
les travaux devraient débuter en 2024
les explications dans ce journal et puis
que s'est il passé dans les yvelines en
2021 au tour cette semaine sur les
événements qui ont marqué l'année au
menu de ce premier volet le résumé de
l'actualité de janvier à mars
[Musique]
selon un sondage ipsos 28% des français
avouent gaspiller de la nourriture
pendant les fêtes consommer autrement
c'est aussi acheter autrement pour
économiser et moins jeter céline roblin
bonsoir vous êtes avec nous merci vous
êtes la dirigeante de l'épicerie zéro
déchet les six poneys du bocal qui situe
à voisins le bretonneux on fera le point
avec vous dans un instant bien sûr sur
ce mode de consommation plus en plus
prisés juste avant je vous propose de
découvrir ces alternatives qui existent
dans les yvelines à maurepas par exemple
les magasins malin et débats qui se
veulent tout comme vous précurseur de
ces nouvelles pratiques plus économique
et solidaire le reportage de mathilde
francou et bixente n'est rien sans
tester balles
depuis le 13 octobre 2021 day by day
gros marché vrac est ouvert à mort par
un magasin de 400 mètres carrés entre
épicerie sèche liquides alimentaires
produits d'entretien et cosmétiques mais
aussi avec des produits frais l'idée
c'était en plus donc de l'épicerie des
bd d'aller chercher des partenaires
locaux engagés
pour m'accompagner sur le même objectif
qui est la réduction des déchets je suis
à les convaincre ludovic biseau par
exemple fromager de rambouillet meilleur
ouvrier de france parmi les autres
partenaires la boucherie cardié situé
dans le centre de maurepas un maraîcher
pour renforcer les circuits courts et le
site de pêche poiscaille qui travaillent
avec des petits pêcheurs en fait et on
peut choisir l'option d'avoir le poisson
chaque semaine livrer ici tous les
quinze jours une fois par mois et ont
choisi deux jours avant la livraison ce
qu'on a envie de manger pour venir faire
ses courses il suffit de prendre ces
contenants ces boîtes pour les remplir
une façon de limiter la consommation de
papier et de plastique il ya des
nouveautés à chaque fois aussi c'est ça
du coup l avantage du brun que c'est que
on peut découvrir des pâtes une semaine
du riz la semaine d'après puis si on
n'aime pas mais on prend un autre
produit après celui de rennes en
bretagne ce grand marché façon day by
day le second en france la ministre de
la transition écologique barbara pompe
il y est venu constater son
fonctionnement une visite qui a
également permis à la ministre de se
rendre à quelques centaines de mètres de
là dans l'enseigne de disques
anti-gaspillage malins qui récupère les
invendus pour les revendre à un prix 25
à 50 % plus bas nous avons ici des
exemples parfaits de la lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire de la lutte pour
gaz aussi lutter contre tous les
emballages qui sont proliférant
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et avec des
moyens simples d'ici à 2030 les usines
commerciales seront contraintes de
mettre à disposition 20 % de vrac dans
leurs magasins
pour ceux qui viennent de nous rejoindre
nous sommes en compagnie de céline
roblin voussoirs dirigeante de
l'épicerie zéro déchet les siphonner du
bocal a besoin le bretonneux alors du
coup céline roblin de plus en plus
d'enseignants on vient de le voir font
leur apparition avec malin le magasin
anti gaspillage et puis le débat idées
et l'enseigne devra convient de mais il
ya aussi votre sociale et donc les
poneys du bocal selon vous est-ce que
c'est plutôt une tendance ou gagne bray
prise de conscience
je pense qu'une vraie prise de
conscience donc c'est vrai quand on voit
le nombre d'épiceries qui ouvre
dans la france entière mais c'est une
prise de conscience et moi je vois au
niveau de mes clients voilà il ya des
gens qui sont déjà dans ce mode de
consommation puis nombreuses années et
on a du cookie qui ont envie et qui voit
là qui vont pas papa petit à petit mais
qui qui ont envie de choses la première
c'est vraiment réduire réduire ses
déchets et et puis après effectivement
le gaspillage alimentaire mais surtout
les déchets je pense donc y en a
beaucoup qui commence à se lancer
justement chez vous on va revenir là
dessus est-ce qu'on peut venir avec nos
propres récipient est ce que vous avez
des beaucoup sur place pouvait
concrètement nous expliquer comment ça
se passe jamais totalement moi je dis
aux gens qui viennent encore découvrir
l'épicerie effectivement que le le
principe c'est de venir etc contenant ce
soit dans pour l'alimentaire pour les
produits d'hygiène et d'entretien donc
et après moi je récupère des bocaux ont
beaucoup de gens m'apportent des bocaux
que je nettoie que je désinfecte et que
je remets ingéré dans la boucle que je
redonne pour dépanner quelques sachets
kraft mais bon idéalement ce serait de
pas trop en prendre ou de les réutiliser
et puis bien sûr je pensais des bocaux
mais je vois beaucoup de gens voient la
vienne commence à venir avec leurs
contenants donc après il faut penser
autrement et quand on va faire ses
courses voilà faut le prévoir on va pas
comme ça un petit peu les mains dans les
poches c'est une petite organisation
différents quoi et justement vous qu'est
ce qui vous a poussé qu'est ce qui vous
a donné envie de vous lancer dans ce
domaine
déjà moi il ya à peu près deux ans et
demi trois ans voilà j'ai un peu pris
conscience de ça donc chez moi j'ai
changer certaines habitudes notamment
tout ce qui est plutôt jetables a
remplacé le film alimentaire par heure
par des découvre plat des choses comme
ça affirmé l'un j'ai fabriqué mais
éponge voilà et puis après j'ai commencé
à aller en épicerie est vrai que c'est
aux déchets et puis bah avec la crise du
coc vite quand même très événementiel
j'ai eu beaucoup de temps de chômage
partiel vers voilà l'idée a germé et
puis je me suis mon signalement vous
êtes lancée mais les avantages du bras
qu'on le disait tout à l'heure il y en a
plutôt pas mal notamment lutter contre
le gaspillage vous le mentionnez tout à
l'heure avec les beaucoup le
suremballage ou même économiser est ce
que vous avez à des exemples concrets de
donner peut-être des chiffres ou les
habitudes des personnes bah après
économisez oui c'est vrai que comme
disait la dame a dans leurs reportages
l'avantagent du vrac c'est comme déjà
quand on s'y met pour découvrir on n'est
pas obligé comme une grande surface de
prendre tout de suite un paquet d'un
kilo enfin voilà on peut prendre par
petites quantités seront aussi produit
convient il revenir notamment quand on
change de lessive ou autres produits
voient la danse et c'est ça qui était
important après économiquement si on
compare parce que qu'ils disent en son
emballage c'est vrai qu'on me propose du
coup beaucoup de produits bio ça va un
petit peu de père et dont si on compare
des produits un prix identique bio
locaux emballer une petite différence de
coût et en est normalement moins cher
sans emballage mais est ce que vous avez
peut-être des as this ou des conseils
justement aux personnes qui veulent se
lancer dans le zéro déchet parce qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément le temps de faire
leurs produits soi même est ce qu'il ya
des petites astuces peut-être après
c'est déjà commencer je sais comme moi
par exemple j'ai commencé plus tôt par
le côté accessoires remplacer vraiment
tout ce qui est jetable donc c'est
facile de remplacer des cotons par des
lingettes démaquillantes soient achetés
soit si on a un peu bricoleur ou
couturier est de faire soi-même dans la
cuisine on peut supprimer facilement le
sopalin film alimentaire des choses
comme ça et puis après effectivement
prendre l'habitude il ya des petites
choses c'est vrai qu'on a un flacon de
lessive pourquoi en racheter à chaque
fois c'est facile à la nuit d'aller
remplir dont il ya des petites choses
comme ça on est obligées de faire tout
d'un coup mais qui pas par petit pas en
prenant des habitudes différentes
ça peut devenir c'est assez simple je
voulais revenir avec vous aussi sur
notamment la loi climat résilience qui a
été donc qui date d'août 2021 c'est
notamment pour lutter contre donc leur
et dérèglement climatique elle prévoit
que les commerces de plus de 400 m² de
vente seront obligés finalement de
dédier 20 % de leur surface au vrac
d'ici 2030 est ce que selon vous c'est
une bonne ou une mauvaise chose je pense
que c'est une bonne chose de se
démocratiser que
et quand on trouve de plus en plus des
produits sans emballage ça c'est bien
après c'est vrai que nous dans les
petites épiceries
de proximité voilà indépendante ou même
les débats et des moules et des
franchises on a aussi ce côté où on
travaille beaucoup avec des produits
locaux en circuit court et c'est ce qui
quand on peut le remarquer je vais voir
en grande surface un petit plus les
rayons vrac et on a quand même beaucoup
de français de produits qui sont pas
français donc effectivement le vrai peut
être aussi moins cher en grande surface
parce qu'on n'est pas forcément sur nos
produits français alors que nous on
prône plutôt le dossier circuits courts
et le produit local donc c'est un petit
peu différent mais après vraiment
démocratiser le zéro d'échelle sans
emballage c'est déjà un pas voilà cette
chaîne est ce que vous vous travaillez
du coup de beaucoup avec les produits
locaux ici et notamment les viennois oui
mais en plus on est en ile de france on
est quand même gâtés avec les
producteurs avec beaucoup de choses et
on peut avoir de nombreux produits
locaux que ce soit de l'alimentaire que
ce soit des produits d'hygiène
d'entretien il beaucoup de l'entreprise
voilà qui propose des choses donc c'est
les gens apprécient ça de voir des
petites pastilles partout produits
locaux produit en ile de france les gens
apprécient donc une tendance qui qui en
tout cas est appréciée de plus en plus
finalement des français merci beaucoup
c'est l'innocence avoir été avec nous je
le rappelle vous êtes la dirigeante des
six poneys du bocal située à voisins le
bretonneux merci
[Musique]
face à la forte demande de vaccination
le département des yvelines relance
l'opération vaccine bus trois bus
itinérant pour toucher l'ensemble des
communes yvelinoise abord médecins
infirmiers et agents administratifs
un dispositif complémentaire aux centres
de vaccination levac six bus feront
étape à proximité des salles municipales
ça se passera à ben demain mardi 14
décembre à vernouillet mercredi 15
décembre aux mureaux le 16 décembre et
puis vendredi à saint nom la bretèche
l'opération se poursuivra après à
montfort l'amaury bréval et l'encours
est et plaisir plus d'informations sur
le site yvelines infos un bateau situé
tout près du centre ville et de la
mairie le quartier des petits prés des
longs cours va bientôt changer de visage
la commune a fait le choix d'une
réhabilitation de ce quartier de 1000
logements accompagnés à du département
et de saint quentin en yvelines les
explications de mélanie bloquer
un bâtiment qui n'existera plus cet
immeuble va faire place à une ouverture
pour rentrer dans les petits prêts à
elancourt 68 logements vont être
détruits le quartier date des années
1980 il s'agira de transformation des
démolitions d'accord mais aussi des
transformations de grands logements
verts des plus petits logements et de la
création du lot ce qu'on appelle du
logement intermédiaire c'est-à-dire
quelques pavillons et aussi des petits
immeubles collectifs de manière à
diversifier l'offre de logement un
projet à plus de 50 millions d'euros un
appui financier est apportée par le
département dans le cadre de priori
flynn le programme de relance et
d'intervention pour l'offre
résidentielle
les bailleurs la ville et saint quentin
en yvelines complète le projet on a une
volonté là d'apporter d'ouvrir va voir
le quartier sur les autres secteurs
comme les horizons par exemple ou alors
le centre d cette mare et puis de créer
de nouvelles circulations douces de
renouveler tous les flux que ce soit
pied tonné ou vélo et puis aussi
automobile pourquoi pas le quartier des
petits traitance centrale est important
d'y apporter une touche bien
particulière des familles seront
relogées en 2022 2023 première étape des
travaux en 2024 la concertation auprès
des habitants se tient jusqu'au 17
décembre prochain le projet pourrait se
tenir jusqu'en 2028
al'approche de la fin d'année nous
revenons toute cette semaine sur les
événements marquants de 2021 première
rétrospective ce soit avec l'actualité
de janvier à mars le résumé par grégory
canal et la riposte s'organise contre le
colis de 19 début janvier les premiers
centres de vaccination ouvrent dans le
département comme à saint quentin en
yvelines où le vélodrome se transforme
progressivement en vaccinodromes des
centres et qu'ils seront même mobile
levac six bus du conseil départemental
sillonne les routes pour aller au
contact des habitants des zones rurales
la campagne se veut progressive les
pharmacies se joignent à l'effort avec
un peu de retard dû à la suspension
temporaire du vaccin astrazeneca les
yvelinois qui vivent au rythme des
mesures sanitaires du gouvernement un
couvre-feu passant à 18 heures des
grands centres commerciaux fermés
notamment un délit zee 2 ou encore 3e
confinement décrété au printemps pour
quatre semaines pendant ce temps là les
restaurants bars ou encore lieux
culturels restent fermés
le tribunal administratif de versailles
annulé les élections municipales de 2020
à trappes en cause le rejet des comptes
de campagne du maire élu ali rabais la
décision sera confirmée en août par le
conseil d'état les trappistes revoteront
en octobre trappe victime de
l'emballement médiatique après les
propos de didier lemaire le professeur
de philosophie au lycée de la plaine de
neauphle parle d'une ville
définitivement perdue est sous emprise
islamiste menace et il quittera
l'éducation nationale pour contrer la
polémique le rappeur saint quentinois
kirtas sortira le morceau trappe qui
donne une image positive de la ville
[Musique]
renault lance arnaud lucioles usine de
flins sur seine sera spécialisé dans
l'économie circulaire le technocentre de
guyancourt accueillir à la software et
publient pour penser avec d'autres
entreprises le véhicule de demain c'est
l'une des mesures du grenelle des
violences conjugales le bracelet anti
rapprochement est déployée dans les
yvelines une convention a été signée au
tribunal administratif de versailles le
latmos installé à vue en cours au coeur
de l'actualité spatiale lancement de son
anneau satellite ubs cussac pour
observer le soleil et la terre
le laboratoire a également développé
l'outil super calmes du rover
persévérance qui va collecter des
échantillons de la planète mars
côté sport le pistard grégory baugé
prend sa retraite celle yvelinois tire
sa révérence après neuf titres de
champion du monde et quatre médailles
olympiques la performance de louis
burton le skipper de rambouillet termine
3e du vendée globe sur son bateau bureau
vallée et pour la deuxième année
consécutive le paris-nice été lancés des
yvelines la course cycliste a démarré de
saint cyr l'école avant de prendre le
départ le lendemain de la petite commune
doivent ils sur mansion
enfin ils nous ont quittés au premier
semestre 2021 jean gombert maire de bois
d'arcy entre 89 et 95 le sergent even
wind tués au mali était né à trappes
marielle de sarnez eurodéputés d'île de
france pendant 17 ans la comédienne
catherine rich dont les obsèques se sont
déroulées à orgeval
le sculpteur gérard amon auteur de
nombreuses oeuvres à maurepas et olivier
dassault fondateur de génération
entreprise
ce week end c'était la quatrième édition
du comptoir de noël au domaine madame
elisabeth à versailles 80 exposants
étaient présents la plupart locaux à
cette occasion la demeure était ouverte
au public et le reportage de célia gars
tsongo et mathilde de franck ou
chocolat biscuits vêtements ou encore
décoration environ 80 exposants étaient
répartis dans des halles couvertes dans
le parc du domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles quatrième édition du comptoir
de noël le service des espaces verts des
yvelines a créé également et celle de
noël
c'est un parent qui fait 8 hectares en
plein coeur de versailles
le domaine de madame isabelle l'avantagé
qu'on connaît ce lieu parfaitement
l'idée c'est vraiment de répartir au
maximum c'est le nombre de personnes à
travers différentes séquences et
différentes scènes de façon indigne et
le fus et surtout avoir des animations
de partout parmi les exposants 80% sont
yvelinois comme l'entreprise les ruchers
d'alexandre situé dans la région du
vexin il propose du miel du pain des
pistes ou encore des sucettes
il s'arrête et des questions
plus de 20000 visiteurs sont venus ce
week end au comptoir de noël avec des
idées précises en tête on est venu au
comptoir vendons notre marché noël on
est bons soirs les petits achats les
tweets ont trouvé des produits c'était
possible et pour la riaa je te conseille
le savions que nous allions retrouver
des stands
avec des choses qui sortaient de nous
cinq courses le 18 et 19 décembre les
animations comme le père noël ou le
labyrinthe seront encore présentes sur
le site laissant le marché de noël
louis xiv organisait jusqu'à trois
soirées par semaine pour les fêtes de
fin d'année chateauversailles ce
spectacle vous fait plonger dans une
atmosphère baroque le temps d'une visite
spectacle le roi soleil et vous invite à
la tombée de la nuit à vivre une soirée
en musique et en danse mathis de franck
ou et mélanie poker garder
au château de versailles la magie de
noël règne en maître pour les fêtes de
fin d'année louis xiv invite les
visiteurs à vivre des moments de danse
et de musique
[Musique]
du moment des fêtes de
pas seulement aux visiteurs
soit ces bruits part du spectacle dans
des lumières
mise en scène
mise en espace
à l'image des fêtes du roi soleil qui
ont organisé trois fois par semaine la
visite spectacle a été pensé par deux
compagnies est un ensemble
[Musique]
certaines pièces y aura des comédiens
dans la cadre des classes on est
la danseurs et quatre musiciens et
ensuite sont
dans la galerie des batailles arrête
cinq séances sont organisées dans une
déambulation dans les salles les plus
célèbres du château tout à fait plaisant
les différents tableaux les uns pour les
autres
magie sont effectivement
des gourmands
c'était charmant
c'était
très beau
et parce que c'est fait ne serait rien
sans son père noël il vient lui aussi de
l'époque baroque avant de s'éclipser
pour aller faire sa tournée
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael et demi d'euros à la
présentation de votre magazine sportif
elle sera accompagnée de bixente mes
liens sont tissés ban pour vos résultats
du week-end très bonne soirée à tous sur
tv 78
[Musique]